[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute geht es mal wieder ein richtig
cooles rezept das oktoberfest steht vor
der tür
ich muss zugeben ich war noch nie auf
dem oktoberfest ich glaube es reizt mich
auch nicht so ganz aber es wird die
saison als oktoberfest darum finde ich
eigentlich ganz cool obatzda habe ich
schon mal gemacht ganz viele tolle
laugenstangen laugenbrezel rezepte eine
riesen brezel habe ich schon gemacht und
was mich schon immer richtig fasziniert
waren laufen ecken die sind nämlich
richtig schön locker wie ein croissant
aber haben eben diesen laugen geschmack
und genau die machen wir heute und ich
hoffe euch gefällt dieses rezept die
laugung ecken die werden aus einem
hefeteig hergestellt und die haben diese
richtig schönen geschichten die stellen
wir durch die butter habt ich zeige euch
mal die zutaten wie habt ihr
wahrscheinlich alle zu hause
das heißt ihr könnt direkt nach dem
video das rezept ausprobieren und dann
auch den posten für den hefeteig
verwende ich einen würfel hefe einen
esslöffel warmes wasser und einen
esslöffel zucker 500 bis 550 gramm mehl
einen teelöffel salz 50 gramm joghurt
dann nämlich den sahnejoghurt 2 eigelbe
250 gramm lauwarme milch 20 gramm butter
150 gramm butter 150 gramm wasser und 50
gramm natron die letzten drei zutaten
hier die brauche ich erst später das
heißt diese jetzt nicht wird im hefeteig
aber ich hab sogar bereit gestellt
zuerst nehme ich jetzt die hefe und dem
zucker und das wasser und verrührte
zutaten kurz
ich habe den ganzen würfel hefe ihr
könnt aber natürlich auch einen halben
würfel hilfe nehmen reicht für 500 gramm
mehl auf jeden fall auch aus so geht er
einfach ein bisschen schneller auf und
mich stört der hefe geschmack ich gar
nicht aber es gibt menschen die mögen
ihn nicht so sehr das heißt sie nehmen
dann einfach mega hefe und lassen den
teig dafür dann länger aufgehen so hefe
zucker und wasser habe ich jetzt in der
rührschüssel den teig könnt ihr gerne
auch mit den händen verkneten oder eben
in der küchenmaschine da kommt jetzt das
mehl dazu erstmal nur ein teil
und ich habe jetzt hier ein ganz
normales weizenmehl 405 ihr könnt aber
auch in dinkelmehl nehmen und 630 oder
auch in instant mail und je nach
milchsorte braucht jemand ein bisschen
mehr oder ein bisschen weniger deswegen
ist auch die spanne 500 bis 550 gramm
wir kommen jetzt noch die übrigen
zutaten rein jetzt der joghurt dann die
beiden eigelbe hier noch die milch und
die zutaten für ruhig jetzt erstmal
und gebt dann einfach nach und nach das
restliche mehl dazu und die weiche
butter die kleine menge weiche butter so
lange bis einfach ein schöner glatter
teig entsteht
jetzt den hefeteig einfach für etwa fünf
minuten treten lassen
jetzt die datei richtig gut aus ich
werde jetzt trotzdem am ende der ist
ganz schön weich hefeteig geht einfach
immer gibt nicht ein großer hefeteig
film ist klebrig ist da noch aber ich
finde es jetzt hier gar nicht schlimm
jetzt freue mich ihnen zu einer kugel
zusammen
es kommt auch ein bisschen back prince
bringt ihnen die schüssel der teig kommt
hinein und darf dann abgedeckt für eine
halbe stunde bis stunde ruhen bis er
sich richtig schön verdoppelt hat
entweder könnte das jetzt in der
küchenmaschine machen falls der hitze
funktion hat oder im dampf backofen bei
gazprom verkaufen gesagt dass backofen
meine ich im dampf backofen bei der
stufe da braucht wirklich nur eine halbe
stunde
der hefeteig ist aufgegangen den hole
ich jetzt ganz kurz aus der schüssel
heraus und wenn man dem und lässt ihn
wärme gibt dann geht es wirklich super
schnell da muss man gar nicht lange
warten
ich lieg den jetzt kurz ab und teilen
dann in acht gleichmäßige portionen 1
und jetzt jeden tag was sie uns zu einer
kugel formen
jetzt hole ich jede teig kugel schön
dünn aus
und wenn ich dann alle ausgerollt habt
kommt wieder die butter ins spiel
jetzt kommt hier immer ein bisschen
butter zwischen die einzelnen
teigplatten und die sorgt daneben dafür
wie bei einem blätterteig oder bei einem
teig dass die schichten auseinandergehen
das heißt je weicher butter hier
einstreichen und dann einfach die
nächste platte drauf nur auf die oberste
teig platte da kommt keine butter mehr
so sieht's jetzt aus und jetzt kann ich
praktisch die laugen ecken rausschneiden
auf dass lily cole matte bitte nicht mit
spitzen messer schneiden am besten mit
seiner teig karte zum beispiel und jetzt
teile ich es einfach in acht teile
du kennst die laugen ecken von becker
und sind die lecker wir werden jetzt
hoffentlich auch lecker city dann ja
gucke ich gehe hier mit der spitze in
die mitte und dann gucke ich hier so
obendrüber ob es die mitte ist
und hinten jetzt auch perfekt und
durchdrücken
super jetzt nehmen wir sie und jetzt hat
die butter noch weich das heißt ich
möchte jetzt dass die butter einfach
etwas fester wird es weg sie jetzt hier
auf dem backblech und klebt dann die
teilchen in den kühlschrank damit
einfach die butter festwirt und sie
gleich schön ihre form auch behalten und
im kühlschrank gehen sie auch auf 11 so
lassen wir mal sie gleichauf gehen jetzt
am besten einfach nochmal eine folie
darüber legen und für etwa eine halbe
stunde bis schon drauf gehen lassen bis
sie sich ein bisschen verdoppelt haben
und bis die butter eben schon fest ist
die ecken sind jetzt richtig schön
aufgegangen und jetzt kommt die
natronlauge
ich nehme dafür einen topf gibt da das
wasser rein und das natron und viele
machen so dass sie die hefeteig teile
dann ins wasser eintauchen
ich mache jetzt so dass ich es einmal
kurz aufkochen lassen und sie dann damit
bestreichen
soviel ich so ein bisschen einfacher und
vor allem geht die form nicht kaputt und
man kann sich nicht verbrennen weitere
vorteile so hier setzt jetzt aber schon
mal die teilchen bisschen auseinander
damit sie beim backen nicht
zusammenkleben das heißt jedes zweite
kommt auf ein einzelnes blech dann
einfach direkt vom herd herunterziehen
und damit bestreichen gar nicht zu viel
dann könnt ihr sie direkt mit körnern
bestreuen mit mohn oder sesam
sonnenblumenkerne das was ihr gerne mag
ich mache es einfach eine mischung
die laufen eckenbach ist direkt im
heißen backofen bei 190 grad ober
unterhitze wenn ihr nur einen backofen
habt und backt sie wirklich nacheinander
und stellt das andere blech wieder so
lange in den kühlschrank damit sie die
form eben schon behalten
so sehen sie jetzt nach dem backen aus
und damit sie ein bisschen glanz
bekommen du sprichst jetzt mit back
trance prey und lasse dann etwas
abkühlen
jetzt sind die brötchen fertig also die
laufen ecken und dem rat dass sie jetzt
probieren lieber morath du hast die ehre
die laugen eckendonk wirklich ich
schwöre der schnitten ja das sind laugen
gründen darüber fragen ja bis jetzt
gedauert das mal ganz ehrlich teig
zubereiten finde ich mir nur aufgehen
lassen halbe stunde 35 rechne ich damit
ja dann hier noch kurz vorm und 15
minuten gespielt 40 50 minuten dann
kühlschrank halbe stunde
jetzt muss ich was ich jetzt mit den 60
er praktisch okay ja so genau wo es gar
nicht bis 120 ich wollte einfach einmal
draußen ist damit sicher manche von euch
geben jetzt sagen solange ein paar
brötchen richtig ist meistens die dort
in den zwei schon über youtube abhängen
und sagen wie es ist zu die zeit wo man
diese brücke sind selbst gemacht so
richtig rund und da kann man morgen zu
dem besuch bekommen oder abends
vorbereiten man kann ja auch einfrieren
und dann einfach nur noch kurz etwas
ganz ganz besonderes bieten um 1
das wirklich selber machen dann geht
nicht hin wollten 15 tipps 17 aufstrich
und 43 wird sorgen sondern probiert es
einmal so weil es ist einfach das
natürlich etwas ganz ganz besonderes und
einfach den geschmack dieses buch ist so
ist ich finde es schön ist dass gerade
so eine wertschätzung ja wirklich meine
brötchen dollar pro bisher und ihr könnt
wirklich mal nehmt einfach weniger hefe
dann könnte sie auch über nacht im
kühlschrank gehen lassen wir noch ein
bisschen millionen
ich dachte da wünscht den foren
geschmack oder obazda obazda das ist
doch eine oktoberfest
ich hab da was ich dass monika
speiseröhre ist ja man sollte halt auch
nicht essen und sprechen gleichzeitig
lieben ich bin hier das essen tut und
ihr redet jetzt und mehreren regen ist
auch die ganzen körper
als die währung essen nicht reden denn
ihr körper darauf hat du musst du machen
wie die ella ella spricht niemals
während sie ist sie macht dann immer
aber wie schmecken die brötchen kommen
super aber ich darf nicht ohne sport
bild wieder etwas im mund und in der
nächsten folge erzähle ich euch wie ich
meinen mann erzählt gestorben alkohol
ist auch gar nicht so gesund lieber was
anderes
sonnenblumen gelassen und wenn du hast
ja auch schlimmer nächstes buch nicht
aufpassen dann sprich nicht wenn du erst
jetzt warte ich bin immer mit ihm
sprechen oder wurde
sehr schön und gutes rezept fürs
oktoberfest oder auch so für das ganze
jahr fürs frühstück und wie gesagt mit
weniger hefe könnt ihr den haag im
kühlschrank aufgehen lassen
dann könnt ihr die brötchen auch schon
vorbereitungen für den nächsten morgen
und dann einfach nur noch backen und
warum der mond berufsleben und brötchen
heute sind meine lieblings brötchen war
sowohl musste nämlich kein monopol auf
die einzelnen schichten die schule sind
ja schöne geschichten so lieber mourad
massi geht noch ein paar brötchen ans
team wir frühstücken jetzt zusammen und
euch menschlich viel spaß nachbacken das
rezept gibt es auch sally bestimmt noch
am tag danach oder sobald frage
natürlich die sind so saftig und in der
app findet iris rezept natürlich auch